why are we friends on the dick Sherlock
Holmes are you just sitting there
inserting an uncertain you stop dry
humping the doorknob was like quite an
array why aren't you wearing a shirt
does it look like I
Salem are together sexual power 2 3 4 5
6 marginal upgrades purchase a marine
weapon upgrade also solid legs slim lead
leg as opposed to what liquid legs are
you implying that my legs are not solid
I think they're implying yet at the
third lake oh well has underbarrel
weapon okay pulse right Oh what haha no
no leave me on what are you doing doing
it wrong here are you deal with it man
oh man he's got this why are they so
easy to like cannon fodder um no I'm
showing off the group the greatness I
guess that's fair wow that texture that
death animation was on par with what ha
ha ha ha ha ha what the hell is
happening a selfie with your camera yeah
he took my cell phone out he's just he's
like man I gotta send this to the Queen
she'll think I'm the pimpest alien
she'll let me fertilize all her face
hugger eggs you seem like spinning
around his tail go through the floor but
go slow and lumbering they are we're in
their supposed to be ultimate hunter ha
ha ha then you're kind of sucking me
one recruiting you just get a wrench
hold on I have an idea no that didn't
even work what okay you know what you
want no no I'm still you know what you
wanted you wanted to not make progress
what am i doing right now mommy okay
that's fun yeah there you go give it to
you there you go I'll let you use it for
another day okay okay no I was you know
I got this for six dollars you're one
got you got ripped off I've gotten
better games for five I got dark souls
for five dollars in de Vere you've got
this verse takes you know what the guy
the guide the front desk actually looked
watered by this game like I think he
actually played it wait what's it on
your posit yeah I have a genuine
question ok ok so did you go the one
next to like cici's pizza and all that
yeah and toys r us yeah is it like
because we're good friends little guys
there well the manager at least was like
the guy with like who had a beard and
glasses and the whole thing uh he had
like like really light blonde hair I
mean it was kind of short and a beard
was he skinny yeah yes so that was
probably the manager that was the
manager he's an awesome guy he knows a
lot about gaming so he probably died
inside you should come in next time you
go there and you should say hey did you
see my friend you some redhead guy
bought colonial Marines he knows exactly
what he was doing can you just give me
like 300 sleeping pills yeah what are
you gonna use these for to get high no
I'm gonna kill myself oh I'm not gonna
like not sell them to you but I still
round two voicecentral gonzo hey we're
retrieving the flight recorder just like
that time this happened in alien acyl
isolation installation installation
alien isolation is just a remake of this
game but good
you can take the [ __ ] admitted to the
Sulaco oh no what are you doing sergeant
okay I can see John your throws ton he
cut his face off hey what's up I like to
think that he just kind of tripped
that's what it looked like though he
wasn't for playing on the easiest
difficulty because who the hell wants to
have a difficult time doing this I like
how he walks all the way through the
door one door they don't come out
through the vents they don't like bust
through the walls or like walking on the
wall I'm walking on the job oh dude do I
get to have this in the first 15 minutes
I'll oh ok well we're making a video
right now yeah you're in it now this is
my video this is my this is my neighbor
/ friend Amy alright well I'm not
cutting this part out is he doing that
missile whoa what is happening yeah her
name he threw a grenade at that one
alien did you do to it no he did there
was one alien he threw a grenade and one
beverage out with three bowls you mean
are you serious you did that much for
that much you blew up the ship that we
could have used to God here are you hi
hey look at that plate where Newt was
running around and there in that tube
there and then the alien was like ah and
then she came out and was like get away
from her you [ __ ] and then they thought
this is basically minecraft no such a
vile an insult it's amazing
oh I have a pistol now oh it looks like
he's filming a rap video that's the car
cover of that guy's album is him
standing over corpses like what wha what
you want there's still anime she going
on so it's it lot like a freeze-frame
death even he just stopped it's like
it's like the death in Grand Theft Auto
but really really bad this vial of Marin
black is such a cheap character you can
just shoot a million bullets and you
can't you can't do anything to stop it
who modeled this look at this did not
use this computer look how tiny this is
xavier all right i am deeply offended he
modeled that my bottles that i was very
proud of that work that fed my starving
mother that's working to modeling this
computer and he just realized that
you've used you click the scale thing to
15 instead of 20 and you felt really bad
you know like oh god Anna that's a week
down the drain Oh son of a [ __ ] gotta
try again oh and then they were like nah
man it's good just leave us you know
what I mean what's this what's his name
wait can they get me if I'm up here Oh
or can they that's really lame they plan
ha ha ha ha ha this recharging the guy
in aliens I ranked up yeah we can barely
do anything man such eyes take situation
we should really fall back to base oh no
we can't handle is guys oh do it they're
like cockroaches you just stand up on a
pond coming out of the wall oh my god
that wall guys it's okay just stand on a
chair we're fine look uh display the
floor is lava you'll be fine hahaha I'm
gonna win good effort into this okay oh
we will what is he doing what hahahahaha
time to get attack what
it's like that segment from halo 4
except I don't even have control so I'm
just watching this gee I wonder if I'm
gonna make it ah heart pounding action
oh wow that was odd record on be a good
heart pounding hop down get er popped
out of his heart are you get hurt are
you serious re ok he just he's done he
just left besides of Ewing at excellent
what the hell is with this what he's
doing a jig for you the walls are
dancing
so far actual the spell from rhino to 3d
read well I'm clear 23 what's your
status woke up gagging on a creature
like a writer gagging on a creature huh
huh that's how you woke up lady ha ha ha
you serious right I will die if it just
cut two credits right now you just start
gagging with choking it down on yours
just like that we ran into Queen shot at
five times it done bang bang bang didn't
do da da son of a [ __ ] it is not
pronounced melee it's melee wait did you
see that this alien just climbed through
the fence not even like he just stepped
over it like it was a rail hey see this
Oh what the hell check on you make sure
you weren't like look they had one
animation of them climbing over a rail
this tall and then they went oh [ __ ] we
have a rail that's too tall over here
what do we do just have him climb over
it the same way even though he's phasing
through the bars like a ghost was that
there's there's a corpse look out haha
he's a star fell out of his chair I was
like trying to do things like closed his
eyes very slowly the exploded the aliens
booby-trapped him they're getting
smarter No can they put a balm any man
you [ __ ] animals variables bed how
can they do this